yo hustle hotcakes we've got a great one
in this episode and today we'll be
talking about Lululemon acquiring the
home fitness startup mirror and of
course the release at Hamilton so let's
get right to it
big news in the athleisure world
Lululemon acquired the home Fitness
start-up mirror for 500 million and and
we're gonna get into what this means for
Lulu according to Bank of America they
believe that mirror to generate 700
million dollars and acquire six hundred
thousand subscribers about 2023 so I
said I've worked in the investment
banking world I could say these are
probably optimistic numbers but even if
you're in that ballpark it's a pretty
strong acquisition considering that
mirrors already do some pretty decent
numbers this is a great tweet from John
Ehrlichman he kind of goes through Bryn
Putnam the founder and CEOs history
before she sold a mere 500 million to
Lulu so ten years ago she retired from
my ballet career opens a boutique
fitness studio four years ago she
pursues the idea to launch a fitness
startup two years ago she releases
mirror and today which was last week she
sells a company to Lulu for 500 million
okay so this second clue we have here
some boys Allie host of the hustles exit
strategy and moist as many of you would
know is no stranger to the DTC Gabe and
he knows a thing or two about nine
figure exits in the TTC space so moist
says Lululemon buying mirror is great to
see Congrats premiere team I think they
need a bet the farm mentality though and
should buy peloton this is probably
referring to Lulu
and he goes imagine a peloton every
store imagine peloton selling Lulu
Studios et Cie Lulu would be transformed
into digital overnight you know what I
gotta say I kind of agree with boys here
so Lulu's a forty billion dollar company
just go for it man just go for it I mean
pellet Oh a little bit pricey that's
about 16 billion so not necessarily an
easy move but sometimes you just gotta
nice watch okay all right third tweet
comes from RAM capital one of the
funniest financial Twitter accounts on
the internet so this one put me in
stitches actually okay so in September
rad capital tweeted imagine turning your
TV sideways and calling it a mirror so
he's referring I'm assuming to mere the
startup and then on the day of the
acquisition he brought back that old
tweet and said imagine turning in TV
sideways and calling it a mirror and
selling over 500 million Telugu now I
think this is a light-hearted joke some
people might be offended but you know I
pulled up a Google Doc just to see if
Ram Capital was even on point here so
here you see in the middle is a mere
product and on the right here I have a
flat screen TV so Ram saying that if you
turn it sideways you're a little bit
comfortable so I'm gonna go right ahead
and do that all right okay this is not
super intuitive okay so there's turn
sideways and listen I'm not saying this
the same thing right I'm just showing
you that it fits inside okay second big
thing this week is Hamilton and we're
gonna pull it up a lot of you I'm
assuming watch Hamilton over the long
weekend and I'm just gonna give the news
right a minute doesn't know Disney Plus
has a live-action version of Hamilton
that is now available it's incredible
you should watch it I was lucky enough
to see it in Boston many years ago not
with the original cast though so no flex
there but if you're to ask me what was
the best hot take related to Hamilton
that I saw on Twitter this week it is
actually unrelated to Hamilton directly
it is directly okay that said this makes
no sense anyways let me get to the tweet
it's Julie bass is 20 year old virtual
effects
tick tock star he released this video on
July the second
[Music]
sweat right so amazing VFX video only 20
years old but has been doing virtual
effects for nine years and he just
treats that video on rights if you all
can retweet this enough times at Disney
calls that'd be greatly appreciated so
it's on July 2nd who responds Disney
chairman Bob Iger right there and he
says the world's gonna know your name
from Hamilton so the best Hamilton
related tweet is about 20 year old
Julian bass who boop the Internet to
education don't forget from whence you
came and the world
Alexander Hamilton amazing video
Julianne's an absolute beast and there's
talk now that he mate might be playing
spider-man Bob Iger do the right thing
made this guy spider-man absolutely
incredible so it's a hot takes for this
week thank you very much we'll keep this
thing going leave your comments and that
there's enough traction maybe we'll do
this more often
thank you